très souvent à la télévision chacun se
plaint de la liberté d'expression qui
seraient de moins en moins présent
toutes les sorties sont matière à
polémique
comme thierry ardisson qui il ya dix ans
jour pour jour décidé de fumer un faux
joint à la télévision pour l'accès à
l'époque le csa avait toléré ce dérapage
qui entrent et pourtant directement sous
le coup de la loi evin qui encadre
depuis 1991 le tabagisme et la promotion
de l'alcool à la télévision ceci est une
publicité contre les ravages de l'alcool
une provocation qui en rappellent
d'autres serge gainsbourg avec whitney
houston en 1986
aw de phoques même gainsbourg autres au
scandale avec le fameux billet de 500
francs brûlé deux ans plus tôt pour
dénoncer les impôts qu'il paye à la fin
des années 80 de chavannes présente sur
tf1 ciel mon mardi une émission de talk
show en direct qui dérape à plusieurs
fois
[Applaudissements]
souvient aussi des répliques incisives
des guignols de l'info qui ne semblait
avoir aucune limite
nan mais j'parle pas d'appétit une idée
de génie saft si au début des années
2000 le discours est moins provocateur
la nudité ne semble pas être un problème
entre les émissions de divertissement et
la télé réalité
tout semble permis c'est à partir de
2008 que l'étau se resserre le csa
annonce de nouvelles mesures de contrôle
des antennes aujourd'hui le sentiment
d'une télé qui s'est calmée ou
l'autocensure et la peur de la polémique
règne semble avoir pris le dessus
alors selon vous la télé est elle
devenue trop chiante alors c'est vrai
qu'il ya dix ans laurent jour ses
comptes 1 un garçon qui travaille avec
nous qui nous a dit ça tout à l'heure
vous thomas ce que tu trouves c'est
devenu chiant aujourd'hui qu'on pourrait
plus faire ça non mais ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'il ya une dérive parce qu'il ya
un certain nombre d'associations dont le
gagne-pain et de de pointer du doigt des
dérives et parfois c'est justifié et
c'est important de le faire et puis
parfois c'est vraiment pour créer un
buzz pour faire parler d'elle ça et
justifier de leur exil les réseaux
sociaux sur la ville et la caisse de
résonance des réseaux sociaux donc je
pense qu'il ya une dérive quand même et
qu'il faut faire attention parce que si
à force de tout aseptiser en europe ne
rien bah c'est sûr
nicolas pernikoff la joie non mais jojo
téléspectateurs nicolas pernikoff était
directeur des divertissements
voilà de france télévisions et de
l'année donc voilà on connaissait bien
le sujet oui c'est vrai que la télé
loris de la télé c'est qu'elle est un
peu aseptisé aujourd'hui vous regardez à
l'époque il y avait eu même il mourousi
qu'il faisait le trésor vous savez qui
est derrière d'élise et ce serait
impensable aujourd'hui de pouvoir voir
un présentateur de jt se déguiser il ya
plus d'humour il se passe pas grand
chose et après l inverse on est choqué
par très peu
en réalité c'est qu'il m'avait faire les
titres du 20 heures ici déguisé en
rappeur alma granitique
ce qui m'anime outre un extrait c'était
dans l'émission hardy matt en 80 12-10
ont menacé de tuer le chien de
l'émission zap
si l'audience du programme descendait en
tout 40 % larmes à sa chose vous
connaissez tous zappe
j'essaie les français aiment beaucoup
les animaux
moi aussi un bon petit japonais les
jolis seins mais très bien toile était
un bon petit à pune j'avais compris s'il
hardy matt descend en dessous de 15%
je bute le club s'est vu monkeys ap
alors soyez gentils et regardez mon
émission jusqu'à la fin des choses quand
on parle de la télé était petit il faut
pas oublier la fois que morose y était
assis sur le bureau de mire un point de
carew est sûre aujourd'hui ça paraît
est-ce que c'était extrêmement subtile
ça ah pardon mais c'est pas donné je
suis désolé c'est pas parce que c'est
aseptisée que c'est pas drôle il peut y
avoir un côté irrévérencieux comme
nounou ya là on touche pas à mon poste
décomplexée c'est ce qu'on a aussi
rejeté envie d'avoir maintenant les
miens six cobayes
allez sur google chine il a pris 3
millions de da d'amendé pour un truc
avec une voix franchement qui avait rien
de scandaleux
on a bien géré sa vérité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ce excuse moi c'est à
cause de la bien-pensance entre ceux qui
font des trucs sur l'étude et oui tu es
ma chambre je serai d'ailleurs quand
même excuse moi fort a pu faire première
fois que sur une émission de t on appuie
quelqu'un pris trois millions d'euros
d'amendés s'était imposé il ya dix ans
où il ya qu un sursis aux faisceaux ont
changé et c'est insupportable
mais j'avais envie de rire comme dans
coco boys des playmates c'était le
principe qui devait se désole
j'aurai une chaîne à soit sur échelle
nationale des films érotiques zone etc
et davina à poils à la maison d'un
générique on n'est pas lui viennent
boire fumer édition ce sont les réseaux
sociaux qui joue intention de tuer la
division je suis désolé le moindre petit
écart c'est le procès et chats le le
moindre mot qui est mal perçue c'est un
scandale sur les réseaux non franchement
bon qu'est-ce qui cartonne aujourd'hui
c'est les endroits où il ya la parole
qui est libéré regarder zemmour cartonné
régler la question de l'anonymat je suis
d'accord mais ça 90% de ceux qui osent
lilly lost tranquillement derrière assez
d'accord en risque les ouïes la télé
doit faire très attention d'accord avec
ça il ya des règles juridiques à
respecter et puis alors que ça peut
engendrer un extrait juliet berto
c'était en 78 regardez ça c'est
complètement fou c'est une actrice qui
fait l'apologie de la cigarette à une
enfant de 11 ans regarder
la personne doit faut déjà 1,5
maintenant que tout c'est une des
raisons pour l'aja bien fumer parce que
j'aime bien la fumée mais voilà alors
bon je voudrais vraiment un coup de
gueule un sautoir
non mais c'est vrai c'est bon je trouve
ça alors ça évidemment dans le contexte
à l'époque la cigarette tout le monde
fumait les comédiens fumée les gens
fumer sur les srd grâce à l'extrême est
juste aujourd'hui on sait nommé
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on est moins
chez désolé on en fait attention on fait
attention il ya encore trois quatre cinq
ans venir déclamer dans télévision
aujourd'hui on peut fond ce que tu fais
une blague c'est mal perçu sert il a été
condamné et pas franchement c'était
totalement injuste et c'était pas du
tout le but est aujourd'hui je vous le
dis les a conduits comme ça on pourra
plus rien faire du tout et on a une
chanson encore en direct nous mais mad
men mais c'est matt pourquoi il fut de
direct parce que dès qu avec ce qu'est
ce qui va éclater à aucune émission en
direct pour dire quoi parce que les gens
ont peut être effectivement aujourd'hui
alors maintenant mais est mort il est
quoi il est plus direct donc le tournoi
parce qu'on se dit comme ça on pourra
couper
donc c'est que l'on va aller et puis on
va raboter les choses et plus
effectivement au bout d'un monde pourra
plus rien d être sa ronde et a atterri
après des choses qui sont répréhensibles
d'accord on est pas tous n'importe quel
président revient sur ce que disait max
si on règle une fois pour toute cette
histoire d'un animal sur twitter verisk
on éviterait beaucoup beaucoup de
problèmes
histoire des tribus d'albi net elle est
juste insupportable et la plupart des
fois où le csa prend parti pour une
histoire c'est à cause de gens qui se
plaignent ceux sur un terrain maintenant
maintenant il faut des étoiles et il
disait il ya eu un signalement sur les
réseaux sociaux il senard a fait
n'importe quoi en plus je vous le dis et
je vous dis il ya des gens dont il ya
des chaînes qui payent des mecs sur les
réseaux sociaux
bien sûr il faudra aller chercher les
autres chaînes mais non non non on ne
fait pas sur ces huit sachets le plus
qu'on n'a pas d'argent ce n'est il ya
des chaînes qui le font c'est qu'ils
font c'est m6 et tf1 vous faut appeler
un chat un chat obèse
c'est vrai ça ce qui évidemment est bien
bien sûr alors dès qu'il se passe un
truc qui mettent leurs mecs lits
disponibles
ils envoient leurs orient qui sont là
qui font des délais jean-michel le plus
triste qu'elle soit ne lui chante oui
mais c'est la société qui met chambéry
l'industrie c'est que la télé mission
c'est de plus en plus ce décalage avec
son décalage avec la vraie vie
pourquoi sur une terrasse de café on
peut fumer à côté de tout le monde
personne ne râle et pourquoi
jean-michel alors arrêtez de fumer est
dangereux pour la santé ça y est c'est
michel aulas jamais du bien
et regardez je suis bête bien meilleurs
sons canada anglais intéresse pas paula
6 janvier merci jean michel jarre né là
c'est presque c'était la télé et ben oui
bah non mais c'est vrai mais on parle
des terroristes dans la vraie vie mais
moi j'ai toujours dit le net
si les terroristes et russe sans une
cagoule
six hommes ce dos il a une seule facteur
est une jeune clavier sur le net
paris les deux là ça rien à voir
l'ardennais que c'est yahia tu sais les
dangers que font les réseaux sociaux
alors vous aussi vous avez vous avez pas
de boire un pastis ou quand même
j'espère y avait dans ce mondial et on
veut pas que ça ou le voilà après vous
inquiétez pas la télévision était
devenue trop chaude jordan est extrait
vous montrez social de charles bukowski
en 1918 drapeau strophe
regardez il est complètement bourré sur
le plateau et moi je te dirai pas ta
gueule mais ça fait rien laisse-moi peut
parler hockey au revoir ok finalement il
n'y a pas tellement la bouteille voulait
la voir ce que pensent les
téléspectateurs je montrais médecins aux
interdits
[Rires]
à
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
magnifique